the last time we talked to
uh that and things have escalated since
then but you
you had said essentially that you'd be
open to working with young boy
and then this video dropped on his
instagram where he was talking
crazy i was like
there's just certain things you don't
say and the way he was talking
and i feel like he does that a lot yeah
and obviously he's the number one
streaming artist
right now in the world right very
talented guy but i do feel like
he is habitually disrespectful right to
the point where it's like
almost there's no coming back from the
level of disrespect he displays online
sometimes
yeah i saw your reply uh
is there an end to that
situation that doesn't involve any
i don't know what's happened i don't
know you know like you said
you lost your partner i lost my partner
only difference is you ain't post them
i don't know if that was for him but
that by the way fireline
love that line but what i'm saying is
i'm not
saying anything has happened or hasn't
happened what i'm saying is is there any
sort of
resolution or are you open to any sort
of resolution that does not involve
any more just ignorant [ __ ] i don't have
no problem with him i was gonna say
you seem like the nicest guy and then
like with that that whole situation like
i mean he was angry he just like talking
about digging up your dead homies i'm
like bro that's
there's certain things it's like
i didn't do so much stuff in life that
you know what i'm saying like
i know who i am so
that that that that role when you got to
prove yourself you got to get like
it it's a few things it's like you
really can't
barely make me angry to where i'm going
to show that i'm angry
you feel me like oh
it's just oh no like i don't know
that yeah i feel like you you're
comfortable in your own skin
yeah definitely you haven't i don't feel
like i've ever
like your comeup did not to me represent
you
trolling on the internet doing that
because i don't have to like i i don't i
don't
i don't got to get on my instagram
playing guns
no you've no 100 i don't i don't gotta
i kill your mama and all that like like
people know who i am
they know what i did and they know what
it would do like i'm i'm good
i'm i'm in a whole different lane in
life not like
i'm not when you saw that though did
that did that make you angry or did you
just choose because i mean
it seemed like your your reaction wasn't
like you know it was kind of like
it was funny it was kind of like bro
like come on bro no he was like really
angry like
he was pissed yo when that [ __ ]
be getting turnt up
i'll be like is he on like what is going
on like and someone take his phone
but did it you didn't react angrily like
you reacted kind of more lighthearted
obviously you talked about you know
like about your voice fat ass no i'm
just saying if if i if
if i wanted to be an angry person and i
like you know what i'm saying like it's
a dirty person like well listen the last
time we talked you were like i'd be open
to working with him
i would i still would i don't i don't i
i'm a business person like i don't have
especially i don't have nothing against
him like he never did me nothing
never did nothing nobody around me was
the original
the origin of the issue with your man g
originally
um i really don't know
like i was listening when i was in jail
right
yeah everybody was good wait just so
everybody know give them the timeline
from what year to what year were you in
jail the two and a half years 2000
the first day of 2016 all the way to the
middle of 20 may
2018. okay so i'm really going like a
little deep with you already i
appreciate it
but i when i went to jail all of us are
good right
yeah but he had left tvg
when i was in jail people
i i don't know the 4k trade [ __ ] came
from all right
it was nba anybody came to nba
they come on my line we eat together we
straight you know what i'm saying it's
like
i think the dude the dude um
i really don't i'm really getting deep
with you i had to do
[ __ ] um like i don't know is it like
when they
bbgs all that like soft side like right
straight ain't nobody
ain't no uh fred i wanna do further
something like
then you you get out of jail and then
[ __ ] goes up i get out of jail like i'm
calling people like what up [ __ ] like
[ __ ] like
[ __ ] calling me hanging up and [ __ ]
like damn
next week on my op like i'm like wait so
he was calling you hanging out no not no
not him there's other people
yeah just like it's just like people
like like fool we were just in jail a
couple months ago we was
making a hookup together hanging out
yeah like making some spreads like
damn like
you would have been comfortable you let
your guard down around these guys all
right damn
and you guys have never had a
conversation together you and and young
boys since
since you got out of jail have you guys
had any sort of dialogue or
no but you're open to it oh yeah
i don't have no problem with this dude
you're bigger than a lot of people man
it's more social media like that's what
it feels like like
if you ain't you ain't giving me none
you need no people nothing like this
hey man that's the same thing i told uh
emily chop when i first met him
i was like yo man you gotta chill out on
that internet [ __ ] bro
yeah and every time i've seen him since
then he's been growing as a you know he
said people forget that dude's a kid
you know you were just with him the
other night right yeah like people don't
realize like he's not even 18. but i
would tell him you know like
yo the internet [ __ ] bro like chill like
like you're a good kid yeah i said like
it's like it is dope to see his growth
but i feel like
like you said you're so comfortable in
your own skin and then like
i'm not about to put my myself at risk
doing this
instagram
i really just was fighting 40 years i
like i
really didn't know if i was coming home
you feel me like i almost like
why would you snitch i didn't actually i
didn't actually slept next to people
who actually have life not people who
who might get it
like i've been next to these people who
are not coming home
like and that's that's like a lot of
people that go to the gym they get out
to go
out and just go out but they never been
there they never got time
and had to really down they need to [ __ ]
my paperwork up
nah they trying to make me do a flat
seven like at first they had my
paperwork [ __ ] up if i have a lawyer
i'd be still in jail seven years just
cause they [ __ ] up my menace
wow feeling like just like [ __ ] like and
imagine how many times that [ __ ] just
happens
so people who just supposed to be home
right right
that's just crazy i'm just making my
money i'm doing my thing
now like you said man i think um
the the the internet beef and [ __ ] is
corny like if it's beef it ain't gonna
be on the internet
and that's you know i mean maybe i'm
just old but
that seems kind of the way you know
hip-hop is going and it's unfortunate to
see